there's drew brees being tended to by
three of his four
children he's got the best medical team
in the world we'll be back
in no time you see he's using the
breathing apparatus that
anyone who's had surgery or a family
member who's had surgery that's a common
device used to get the lung capacity
back to where it needs to be and that's
important for drew brees because edward
of espn reported
on monday chris that brees has five
fractured ribs and a collapsed lung
so he's got to do some work to get the
lung back to where it needs to be
the ribs will heal in their time
depending upon the severity of the
fractures i remember there was a time
donovan
had a broken rib and there was a concern
that the rib wasn't if the ribs got to
be sticky
it's got to be adhering to the rest of
the rib because otherwise it starts
you have a piece of bone you have a
piece of bone
that is floating around right in your
uh internal organ cavity which i'm no
doctor
that sounds like probably not an ideal
situation no
it's not an ideal situation you know the
the collapsed lung
i don't know a lot about that one um i i
don't
so i'm sure there's some things you you
got to work with there to
get that back up to speed strength all
those type of things
we talked about it yesterday you know
ribs are tough
ribs are tough no matter what let alone
oh man i got to extend my body and
create this torque and throw a football
and do those type of things
you know and i think you and i have had
confidence conversation off camera you
don't have to break your ribs
i mean even if you got poles in the
cartilage in between the ribs and things
like that
can be incredibly annoying and painful
and especially
for a thrower you know where you have to
raise that arm and create that torque
all the time and
that's going to be to me the thing that
i just go
ooh you know how bad is it in there how
much pain is he going to be able to deal
with
you know and it might be a few weeks
before he feels like he can really cut
it loose
and you know throw balls 15 and 20 yards
with some pace on it
i fell down a hill when i was 14 years
old and broke multiple ribs
and everything hurts breathing
yes hurts and and then
on the night it happened or maybe the
next day and i'm laying in bed
immobilized here come the hiccups
there was no pain i've ever endured in
my life like hiccups on broken ribs and
i learned in that moment
how to mentally harness your diaphragm
and make the hiccups go away
the pain was that bad so everything
hurts and he's got
five of them and and and here's the
thing
there's a little bit a shell game that
always goes on with nfl injuries
he was on the injury report the past
couple of weeks with a shoulder he was
limited in practice
and then then there were reports that he
already had
fractured ribs before this and nobody
knows what the truth is
and the teams know there's strategic
value in deliberately obfuscating
because if you say he's got a rib
problem what are you doing
you're painting a target on each side of
his rib cage
for defensive players to come after
here's sean payton yesterday talking
about the situation with drew brees
and also uh who takes over if brees
can't play
i remember last year when when drew was
injured in
seattle you didn't name a starring
quarterback until late
into the week um that'll be the case
this week too
okay yeah i was just going to bob and
what fair enough
maybe could you maybe the process of
what goes into that is it this week in
practice is a game plan
probably a little bit of all of it yeah
a little bit of all of that
and also none of it benefits us
by announcing that player earlier than
later
you know it's funny sean payton can be a
very affable friendly gregarious guy but
when
injury is the subject matter he
slips into the personality of yev kasem
otherwise known as the soup nazi
but you know look that's the old school
bill parcells approach
why do you say anything about it you're
not saying anything about it anything
you say can and will be used against you
no of course not and then especially
when one of the quarterbacks could be
taysom hill
you know that is going to make
whoever you're playing just worry about
all the ways he can attack you with the
quarterback runs and all the creative
things that way so
that's what he wants to do he wants to
be able to go
wait you got to worry about defending
the drew brees
offense with jameis winston at
quarterback and i know that might not be
exactly the same but
in theory it's gonna still be the saints
offense of what they do
and oh wait wait taysom hill might start
and that could totally change and now
we're a run first team
and might have all these bells and
whistles and everything like that run
the ball run the ball run the ball
and we take deep shots down the field
with max protection and only two
receivers
so yeah that that's that's a schematical
advantage for them
and i think peyton's gonna you know sean
payton's gonna ride that home
i think it will be jameis winston though
in my heart of hearts i do
for the one reason mike and i don't know
you tell me what your you know
pasta and meatballs in your stomach tell
you after this but
like i just we haven't seen taysom hill
pike quarterback yet
how many reps has he gotten throughout
the year to play quarterback and do
those things
you know that those are the things i
don't know to where
hey it'd be one thing if he was
full-time quarterback
full-time back up and he hadn't played
that's okay
okay yeah he's getting reps all that but
you know think about yeah he's
quarterback
but he might be down with the wide
receivers he might be with the running
backs he might be doing this
so how many reps has he got to really
run within the offense
since training camp as far as just
running the drop back part of it
and that's to me where i think it'll end
up in jameis winston's hands where
he runs he's quarterback and then we see
taysom hill just have a role in the
offense
but is that what we see or is that some
hill preparing to be the backup to
jameis winston and no taste
and no taste in hillary package yeah i
think that last year
teddy bridgewater was the quarterback i
think that's what it'll be i think
you're not going to see a taste in hill
package and you're going to see him
in the offense you know to catch some
balls and things like that but i think
they'll be careful with them
because they're gonna worry again hey
let's give the saints credit
they got a super bowl team and they went
out and got a big time backup
quarterback once again
and let's see hopefully it saves their
butt once again
um but yeah i i think
i i i think that's probably the way they
go because they don't want to risk
losing taysom hill and jameis winston
and then
bye bye season or bye bye two games
we've lost and now we're in trouble
here's the thing that that sticks out
for me and there's two
that's the top first yeah and and this
is
the simplest level of logical analysis
that i can engage in which is also the
most complicated i can engage in
last year when drew brees got injured
week two against the rams with the thumb
problem that required surgery and he
missed several weeks and he came back
and teddy bridgewater went 5-0
the depth chart that they always
downplay oh we only do this because we
have to well it's still
a link on your website you pull it up
and there it is drew brees one
teddy bridgewater two taste some hill
three next man
up made sense yeah right yeah jason
hill's not to back up
teddy is of course he takes over this
year
that depth chart that every team has and
whenever
anyone tries to rely on they say oh pay
no attention the man behind the curtain
drew brees won taste some hill two yeah
jameis winston three and you throw on
top of it
the contract that was given to taysom
hill in the off season right
the the the two-year deal with 16
million guaranteed
uh you know what what are they paying
him for i know because they sure don't
they sure don't use him
on the offense like like he gave him 16
million guaranteed
and if you're ever thinking about making
this guy
your quarterback post breeze don't you
want to find out
at some point what what he can do
you know yeah we've we've used this
sports car
analogy with him in the past you've
bought it
it's in your garage you're taking it out
for like random spins but you're never
really finding out
everything it can do you're never
dropping the pedal to the metal
you're never putting it in a spot where
you know you see how it handles and what
you can accelerate it to and
hey if you think this guy can be steve
young and we didn't say that
sean payton said steve young if you
think he can be
that put him on the field while he is
young
mean he's pushing 30 if not over 30.
let's see what the guy can do
you're going to trust him presumably at
some point to be your quarterback
put him out there let's let's go let's
see what he can do this time i know
that's what i would do
and if you don't do it it makes me
wonder what the hell is really going on
with taysom hill
well i it i mean listen it's a tough
spot i i mean it really
you know i think the guy has talent sean
payton recognizes that
he didn't get to play a ton of
quarterback he has plans for him
to be yes maybe a future quarterback
but either way i think part of paying
him was just to keep him here for the
future too
because of wait maybe he's the
quarterback maybe he is just a full-time
weapon h-back tight end slot receiver
running back type of guy maybe that's
what it is i think it's all on the table
still
and that's really why they paid him and
i think sean payton looked at it and
went
you know this is kind of my my joker
here and i i can use it in a lot of
different ways
and i don't want to lose him as far as a
weapon right now or
a potential starting quarterback down
the road and that's
it is a really tough decision this week
i don't know where you're going chris
yeah hey at some point yeah at some
point you're gonna have other guys in
that locker room
looking to taste some hill saying why
are they paying this guy so much money
and why am i not getting that kind of
money yeah i mean it's all it's kind of
like the
the matt ryan julio jones of effect
where
you know when when matt ryan gets to 30
million a year and julio jones is at 15.
he's like what's wrong with this picture
this guy isn't twice as valuable as me
so if you're alvin kamara michael thomas
some other key piece of the puzzle
and you've got this guy who makes cameo
appearances and we know he can be very
good
but he's only used sparingly at some
point you're like what
what's going on here and i think that
has been the nagging
question with the saints and taysom hill
all year what's really going on here
and if jameis winston ends up playing
quarterback and we don't see taysom hill
on the field at all because he's number
two
uh i think that the question becomes
even more pronounced what what's going
on with taysom hill in the saints yeah
i don't disagree i mean it's going to
open up a can of worms to where people
are going to wonder
yes is he really the future of the
franchise that quarterback what's the
story why aren't we playing them
um but but that's where you know again i
think that's
going to be a little bit about where
he's at in this season
you know we're 10 weeks in you know i'm
sure he does
some quarterback stuff but how much of
the day is he really there
you know going through the nuances of
the offense
oh it's individuals you know it's
individual drill time
quarterbacks are over here receivers are
over there running back show that is he
always with the quarterbacks
i doubt that i i wouldn't imagine i
think there's probably certain scenarios
he is but other ones where he's down
there with the receivers and the running
backs and figuring things out that way
too
and that's to me the big question or the
thing we
will we'll figure out i guess is just
where he's at in that process
and can they trust him to run you know
a semblance of the sean payton drew
brees type offense and he can do all of
that stuff
let alone some of the stuff he does you
know as well and i think that's where
it's risky and that's where sean
payton's probably gonna have to evaluate
it during the week
and as what's gone on during the season
the good news for the saints the
schedule is far from
daunting in the indian future in fact
when you look at the balance of the
schedule
you really don't have many games that
scream out uh oh you got a problem the
next three
should be no problem although the falcon
saints rivalry
is very very intense they play twice in
three games with the broncos in between
yes and the falcons have won three of
their last four so this is not a gimmie
and raheem morris the interim coach of
the falcons mentioned yesterday well i
guess we're gonna have to prepare for
both guys
jameis winston and taysom hill and that
may simply be
what what sean payton is trying to do
now i think the
challenge comes wednesday
as of wednesday and and so many coaches
have tried this unsuccessfully you can't
keep everyone quiet someone is going to
say
something to someone about who was the
first string quarterback
at practice on wednesday that's when
we'll know
there will be a report from someone
wednesday afternoon
early evening at the latest as to who
got
the bulk of the first team reps at
practice on wednesday and that'll be our
first clue as to whether or not it's
jameis winston or taysom hill but
you know tuesday is the big game plan
day and i know the falcons have the
capacity on the fly to come up with
whatever they need to do and they've
dealt with jameis winston they delivered
the death blow to his career in tampa
bay
they've dealt with taysom hill they they
just
they they are going to need to be ready
for both and
uh until further notice it could be
either guy and there's still a chance
that it will be both guys maybe they
just
maybe just use both i agree i mean i
don't think that's crazy this year
i don't you know you know jameis winston
you know new system things like that
maybe this is the way he takes a little
pressure off of him too
and they use a little bit more i
wouldn't be shocked to see that this
year i wouldn't
to where maybe sean payton risks hey
let's i'm going to throw taysom hill out
here a little bit more
quarterback and do those type of things
and then he doesn't maybe have to ask as
much
of jameis winston i think it's a
possibility certainly and like to the
point with the falcons you're talking
about mike too
it is real yeah the falcons aren't as
good as the saints but raheem morris
knows this sean payton offense you know
all those years he had in tampa coaching
against gruden and those things
a lot of similarities that's why they
had success last year
they took away some of the staples of
the saints
and i think that'll scare the saints too
to where maybe that's where
the taysom hill part of the offense
comes into play a little bit more to add
another curveball
you know to their attack quick question
quick answer under the time-honored
notion of putting the best 11 guys on
the field
who's better taysom hill or jameis
winston oh
i'm gonna go with james winston i don't
it that's close
that's close it really is but i just
haven't seen taysom hill play enough
quarterback
yeah taysonville's a better football
player but i can't say he's a better
quarterback than jameis winston and i'm
kind of excited to see what jameis
winston
can do in a sean payton offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports